what's up you guys doing another movie
retrospective going back again to the
1950s
a cheesy horror classic
starring man myth legend vincent price
yeah probably one of my favorites hot
ass vincent prey is probably one of my
favorite yeah he looks really good at
this yeah he's he's a handsome man he's
the headset the younger he was better
the better he looked he was aged well
though he aged well he did yeah he was
actually like a cool as [ __ ] looking old
dude too because he was in you know
edward says her hands and stuff yeah he
looked all like ghoulish but still kind
of like hot actually that dr phi dr
fives was good
everything he's in is good if he's in it
i'll watch it i don't give a [ __ ] like
what the rest of the movie is like but
honestly house on haunted hill is one of
the ones that keeps getting brought up
all the time this came out the same year
in 1959 as the tingler uh i like the
tingler as well
but i kind of like this one better just
because i think this one has less
i feel like the tingler is like a cool
concept and it has like more body horror
thing we talked about that a couple
weeks ago but it has a lot of
kind of downtime
and i feel like house on haunted hill
doesn't really have that house on
haunted hill is like pretty
fast paced in the sense that there's
always something like creepy happening
and i tend to like haunted house type
stories better than more sci-fi type
stuff even though technically you could
say and this is going to have spoilers
obviously because this movie's so
[ __ ] old and it's been remade we'll
talk about that a little bit too
but
technically
this might not be a haunted house movie
it might not be supernatural they kind
of leave it ambiguous
as to whether because the [ __ ] that
happens in the movie
is pretty much not it's like some
scooby-doo kind of [ __ ] like a person
did it but
it's you know it still like left it
possible that there's ghosts you know
what i'm saying it's not my kind of
movie but
yeah but it i mean it is like super
cheesy fun i've seen this a bunch of
times um so when i was re-watching it
for this show i watched the colorized
version
that they did on rifftrax live like from
back in 2010 that was like their
halloween show back in 2010 they've done
a regular version of it as well and i
also have a dvd version uh that just has
mike nelson's commentary on it the
reason they keep going back to this one
and night of living dead and stuff like
that is because i'm not sure if you know
but house on haunted hill from 1959 is
in the public domain okay so if you go
on youtube uh there's 40 bajillion i
mean this is really really easy to watch
and i feel like everybody has probably
seen it at some point it's not a bad
movie but it's a movie the 50s uh well
sure it's a little more wild than the
average movie the 50s but it's not quite
as good as it was until you know
the [ __ ] price was doing in the 70s and
the 60s to me was like a lot better
but it it's it's a decent watch yeah i
mean i'm honestly i kind of like i know
i said that maybe this was my favorite
role of his but now i'm thinking about
the roger corman poe adaptations yeah
and i kind of feel like mask of the red
death may be my favorite but he's great
in this one too
and the thing about this one is that
he's not really i guess it's kind of
left again ambiguous as to whether he's
a villain or not
i mean it's possible that he's a villain
or it's possible that he's like a victim
of a villainous scheme
uh but you know again it's kind of left
uh ambiguous
so uh much like as the case with the
tingler
this was made by uh gimmick king william
castle uh the gimmick in this one was
not quite as cool as the one for the
tingler with like all the vibrating
boaters under the people seats this one
just had something called emergo
which toward the end of the movie like
at the climax when the skeleton comes
out of the acid bath or whatever like
the acid pit that everybody has in their
basement um when that comes out like in
certain theaters they would have a
plastic or an inflatable skeleton that
was like on this rig so it kind of
looked like it was coming out of the
screen emerging emerging emerge
they didn't do anything to get these
kids it worked it worked let's go see a
merger oh that's emerging
a little kids though they're from thrall
but it was just like fun and honestly
the way that william castle approached
the movies was that he wanted it to be
like a carnival ride like you'd ride
like the carnival fun house so it's not
like nothing too scary or anything like
that but the similar kind of thing so i
kind of feel like this is a movie that
you know kids can watch it because it's
not really all that scary and it's kind
of like a halloween type of movie you
know what i mean just because it's kind
of old-fashioned and kind of cheesy the
[ __ ] gimmick to get the kids to come
in yeah but just like fun right so
selling boobs
yeah that's so they had to come up with
something yeah it was later on they just
put boobs in it
they knew what they were doing yeah just
like in the first two minutes like boobs
everybody's like all right gotta fight
out my attention
yeah they couldn't do that back then so
you had to do kind of more and like i
said i kind of feel like these were
maybe geared towards maybe slightly
younger right that's what i meant that
yeah didn't show young kids so they had
to do [ __ ] like that but later on
[ __ ] horror movies
a lot about boobs and they had kids in
there i feel like this is a good
probably not so much nowadays because
it's really old but i feel like this is
a good if you want to introduce your
kids to horror because i know that like
you know people my generation they're
super into horror and try to like
they're always kind of like what's some
kid-friendly stuff that it's like i want
to get my kid into horror but i want to
like traumatize them for life or
anything so what are some good sort of
kid-friendly
horrors and i think this is probably
like a decent one to start with because
it kind of has some creepy [ __ ] in it um
like that one jump scare with that old
lady who looks like really horrifying
yeah i thought she was this is the woman
who played the [ __ ] wicked witch of
the west margaret hamilton that was her
but it looks like her but it's not she's
under kind of like a lot of yeah she's
just one of those witchy looking ladies
yeah um but yeah so interestingly i was
kind of like looking uh into the
background of this movie like into you
know we talked a little bit about
william castle but i'll get back into
that in a little bit this was actually
written by a guy named rob white
and he also wrote the screenplay for 13
ghosts which is interesting because this
movie and 13 ghosts have almost the same
premise pretty much and they were both
remade like in the late 90s early 2000s
by the same uh company all kind of
production company i'll get into that
although the guy that wrote this
interestingly was pretty well known for
writing like adventure fiction like he
was a veteran so he wrote like all this
kind of world war ii adventure fiction
and he also wrote stuff for like what
they would nowadays call like y a novels
and he had like a bunch of his stuff
adapted to film uh and [ __ ] like that so
i thought that was kind of interesting
but i just thought it was interesting
the same guy wrote 13 goes it shouldn't
be that surprising because they're both
like really similar but uh yeah so
what you have too
um is the house where it was filmed
interestingly you see the poster like i
love the original poster for house on
haunted hill but the house that's in
that is clearly not the house that's in
the movie obviously and on the poster it
looks like this creepy like old
you know like a haunted mansion
the but the um house they used for the
actual movie was a very famous house
called ennis house which is in los feliz
california uh which was built by or
designed by frank lloyd wright and it
was supposed to resemble a mayan temple
uh it's still there i think they used to
do tours of it although i don't know if
they do anymore just because it's kind
of old and there's like safety concerns
but that
uh that kind of like weird-looking house
has been used in like a [ __ ] ton of they
used it in blade runner
uh they used it in dave the locust they
used a karate kid 3 which i thought was
like really funny uh they used it in
black rain that ridley scott movie so
it's a very very famous like la landmark
so they actually used that for the
exteriors obviously the interiors were
done all on a
sound stage
so as i said william castle uh prior to
making
the movie macabre which came out in 1958
like a year before that he was kind of
more like a hollywood guy but he did
more like noir type stuff he didn't
really do horror
but in the 50s i guess he kind of became
disillusioned with the hollywood system
i guess like the way you know they keep
[ __ ] around the movies and you know
changing their [ __ ] and so he said i'm
going to go independent
and so macabre was the first one he made
and i think we talked about on the
tingler how the gimmick for that
was everybody that came to see the movie
they'd give you like a thousand dollar
life insurance policy if you died of
fright during the movie
uh so that was the gimmick for macabre
and that was like a huge success so he
said okay well this is what i'm gonna do
now i'm gonna make these really low
budget but just kind of fun carnival
type
horror movies that have a gimmick so
it's like really successful
interestingly because of the success of
william castle's movies particularly
this one
uh alfred hitchcock now william castle
was a big fan of hitchcock's he would
even do like hitchcock kind of [ __ ] like
uh turning up in the trailers for his
own movies and stuff
but when alfred hitchcock saw what
william castle did with house on haunted
hill really really low budget
uh horror film uh with a gimmick and it
made all this money he said i'm gonna
try that out and he made psycho
so interestingly and then like later on
so they kind of had like a mutual
influence type of thing
so i have seen like some kind of horror
historian type people
speculate that had alfred hitchcock not
seen house on haunted hill and like how
successful it was he might never have
made psycho
and we might never have had like the
slasher film genre or it would have
happened like a lot differently than it
did happen or happened later i think it
would have happened anyway but it might
have not happened the same way that it
did happen because we did have um there
was another movie that came out in 1960
which we've covered which is peeping tom
which was also like a slasher movie as
well so any of you all have not seen
[ __ ] psycho you're [ __ ] bad you're
just bad it's just one of those things
that
it's even if you're not like a horror
movie
nerd you got to see it i mean definitely
if you're a horror movie nerd you have
to see it it's well written super well
written it the the story pulls you in
even though you know it it's an old
movie it's still very effective and all
of the sequels that came after it were
good they were all real good yeah
they're all worth watching there wasn't
any bad ones and [ __ ] anthony perkins
[ __ ]
he [ __ ]
he [ __ ] blows you out of the water
with ev with each um sequel there's like
five of them and five i think five right
uh four yeah they're all good and then
they did the series bates motel yeah
which i still haven't watched yet yeah i
think we have it i think somebody sent
it to fate's motel but we haven't
watched i think i watched the first one
but i just got it somebody said a hard
copy i think so i think i saw it in the
in the band cave oh i'll go i'll go chat
i'm pretty sure that somebody sent us
that series but yeah so i just think
it's really interesting that maybe
the the way that like the slasher genre
genre ended up playing out or the way
horror movies ended up playing out post
psycho because that was like a huge
milestone
might not have happened in that way if
not for house on haunted hill which is
crazy because like i said it was alfred
hitchcock being like hey i i'm gonna try
doing what that guy is doing you know
what i mean and then like later on uh
you know sort of william castle kind of
like return the favor i guess like 1961
he made a psycho rip-off called
homicidal which you know so they were
just kind of going back and forth it's
just kind of like the italian giallo
movies and the american slashers it just
seemed like one influenced the other and
then that one went back there since it
was like this big feedback loop so it
was that type of [ __ ] too now it also
should be noted that william castle i
think i might have mentioned this before
but
he actually even though he's kind of
known as like the gimmick king and like
making these kind of schlocky fun
carnival rides sort of horror movies he
was actually really serious about horror
and he actually wanted to make house on
haunted hill he was sort of doing a riff
on shirley jackson's novel the haunting
of hill house which had come out the
same year uh earlier in the same year
and was kind of like really successful
and as i mentioned on another show he
actually when
actually before the
book of rosemary's baby came out the
ireland novel he recognized oh man that
would be like a great movie and he
bought the rights
while it was still like in the proof
stage before it was even published and
he was actually gonna direct it but you
know various things happen and he didn't
end up but obviously ron polanski ended
up doing it and it was a classic but he
did actually recognize good horror when
he saw it is what i'm getting at
so
what i kind of feel like okay so if you
haven't seen this movie as i said it's
in the public domain so you can probably
just see it it's on youtube it's on 2b
it's on it's everywhere because it's
free
but what you have is vincent price plays
this kind of eccentric millionaire type
guy
and
the house on haunted hill is not his
house
he rented it uh from another guy
so he could throw a party for his wife
now his wife this i think she's like his
third fourth wife or fifth wife or
something like that and the best thing
about this movie just like the best
thing about the tingler
is that
vincent price at the woman uh carol
omart who plays his wife
absolutely despise one another and it's
glorious i mean she is he basically is
making jokes so they have these great
like conversations where he's just kind
of like remember all the fun we had when
you tried to poison me and like all that
other kind of [ __ ] it's so awesome but
she's just like i don't know i don't
even know what you're talking about blah
blah blah so it's just kind of like all
the back and forth between the two of
them like talking about how much they
hate each other is just like excellent
so there's this whole thing about
he he throw is throwing her the party
but then they invited
all these people that are just like
random like they don't know them really
they don't know the guests don't know
each other
he just picked them because he's like
well these were just people that i knew
of that needed money
so basically the setup it's kind of like
a game setup obviously like some later
movies like would you rather and stuff
they're like i just found some desperate
ass people and sent them invitations you
have to come stay in the house on
haunted hill
you stay here one night
uh and don't die and you'll each get ten
thousand dollars
but then it seems as though
when they all get there
uh he kind of makes it so they can't
leave because he's like well after
midnight we're just gonna lock the [ __ ]
up and you can't leave although he gives
them like an opportunity to leave
beforehand
now the thing about it though is that
you're not entirely sure
because he keeps saying that it was his
wife's idea for the party and she's just
kind of like well it was my idea until
you invited all these people who the
[ __ ] are these people but they're doing
this whole like thing so
after all of the people are locked
inside
and kind of start to
wander around the house
uh you know various scary things start
to happen you have like the one chick
who is named nora who is quite a
screamer holy crap
but she i guess works for one of vincent
price's companies but he didn't really
know her but you know she needed money
so she came there
and
she is kind of like
the one that it seems like most of the
haunting or whatever it is targeted
toward
uh so she kind of goes down to the
basement exploring and she's the one
that gets that like old lady jump scare
in her face which like i said is the
very most effective jump scare in the
movie by a mile because that woman does
look really freaky and then like after
that after she's scared by the old woman
the old woman like kind of floats out of
the room like she's on a skateboard like
which is actually is like pretty cool
because i was like watching it go that
is pretty creepy i mean that's just
creepy that her just like walking out
but the thing about it is that they
don't
okay so i don't know if you guys know
but
the the guy that owns the house he's
convinced that
it's haunted because he's like look my
brother was murdered in here all these
people were murdered in there we're not
saying that but he's convinced that all
of these ghosts are still there and the
ghosts are the ones that are like start
or killing people but as it turns out in
this particular case
you're kind of left it's left ambiguous
as to whether it's actually ghosts or
not because you find out that vincent
price's wife has kind of engineered a
lot of the [ __ ] although if when you're
watching it they're like some of the
[ __ ] that happens in there i'm like how
the [ __ ] did you pull that off i don't
really know so they kind of leave it
ambiguous as to whether maybe it's
ghosts but what she does is she
not too long into the movie
commits
suicide um
but then they're like well she had to
have been murdered because she was
hanging there like up by the ceiling but
there was nothing for her to like step
on or anything so somebody must have put
her up there
but it turns out though that her and one
of the other guests who's like a
psychiatrist who studies hysteria
uh are like [ __ ] and so they're like
in cahoots and their whole elaborate
very convoluted plan
is that they wanted him to invite all
these people to this house and then they
would make it seem like it was haunted
so one of them would freak out
and kill vincent price so they could be
like i don't know what happened man like
somebody just flipped out because of the
ghost and killed him we didn't have
anything to do with it so it was like
like i said like a very convoluted plan
where they were gonna do that
and it seems like it's gonna work out
because
you know the the girl nora that they
kind of
are trying to scare into shooting
vincent price's character she does shoot
him
but uh it turns out that vincent price
was on this [ __ ] plan all along and
loaded all the guns with blanks
everything because they give all the
guests like guns at some point too but
you know so this movie is like
it's quite short i think it's only 80
minutes long if that
uh so a lot of the middle part is kind
of like
just the guests sort of like wandering
around around the house and getting
scared by various things as i said some
of the scenes are quite effective the
one with like the old lady the scary old
lady that's pretty good and i also
really like the scene where nora looks
out her window and sees what she thinks
is the ghost of the wife like kind of
floating out there like in her nightgown
and then like the rope comes in and sort
of like goes around her feet and stuff
which again i don't know how they pulled
that off
if she wasn't a ghost because she wasn't
but
you know so so i don't know so i feel
like the middle part of it is just kind
of like a lot of wandering around but
that said
the house looks so cool and vincent
price is so cool that it doesn't that
i'm not even mad about it you know what
i'm saying and i honestly really like
the end with the acid bath and the
[ __ ]
because who has that it's like well it
seems like when they do like the tour at
the beginning of the house because this
is a very kind of like fourth wall
breaking sort of movie because you have
like vincent price and you have like the
guy that owns the house like at the
beginning like talking directly to the
audience like talking about all the [ __ ]
that happened in the house and they do
kind of like a tour and he's talking
about you know this person died in this
place and everything and in the basement
there's this big [ __ ] pit that has
like all this acid in it well you some
dudes have those
[Laughter]
and then like it just has this like a
trap door like a big trap door you like
lower over it and everybody's like did
anybody think like because somebody got
killed in there in that acid vat and the
guy that owns it whose brother was one
of the people murdered i don't think he
got put in the acid but some other
people did you would think that now that
guy owns the house you'd think that he'd
maybe want to have that pumped out i
mean it seems like a safety hazard i'm
just saying
um maybe there's not really a service
that will come in there and like pump
acid out of your basement but
you would think that if that was your
house because i could just see myself
going down to do laundry one day and be
like
like fallen into the [ __ ] acid pit
you know what i'm saying i could see
that happening all right well jenny
likes a movie to me
it's a 50s movie it is i'm not saying
yeah let me finish that i'm gonna say
50s movies when it comes to horror
they felt to me very same same-ish
uh it's very rare does one jump out at
you
now
it's because of the haze code [ __ ]
1930s horror was a lot better all right
um
when it comes to 50s
sci-fi was better in the 50s if it was
real high-end like war of the worlds and
[ __ ] forbidden planet
because they could do more wasn't much
they could do in horror
in in the 50s it was
especially especially for so so they
made it for kids a lot of times
so
it wasn't until later in the 60s he
asked me that's really when [ __ ]
horror started to come
become something when they had a rating
system so they could make something
rated r
thank you
yeah i mean honestly if i'm you know if
i'm being honest the 50s isn't my
favorite so and the 50s isn't my
favorite decade uh largely because a lot
of it was sci-fi yeah and a lot of it
was like really cheesy b sci-fi which
sci-fi isn't my favorite subgenre anyway
they could get away with more sci-fi but
sci-fi yeah they could get away with a
lot more but the thing about house on
haunted hill this is kind of like late
50s
but
it was actually essentially a little bit
parodying
the sort of old dark house
uh kind of trope because even in 1959
that was old that was like tired they
had done that back in the silent movie
era that was that had done back in like
agatha christie type of stuff and like i
said it's almost kind of like house on
haunted hill it almost works a little
bit better as like a noir type like a
murder mystery because it's essentially
more like a murder mystery than a ghost
story because you don't actually know at
the end of the movie if they're if the
house is actually haunted or not because
a lot of the stuff was engineered by
either vincent price's character or uh
his wife annabelle in the 50s they could
horrify you with sci-fi aliens coming to
attack you [ __ ] other planets [ __ ]
scary [ __ ] there
because because there's a sci-fi setting
behind it so there's supplies there's a
plausibility yeah there's a monster
oh it's on another planet
but when it came to horror now it has to
horrify you so you're talking about
murders and [ __ ] bodies and ghosts
and [ __ ] like that
but they were limited in what they could
show you getting horror so
the horror of the 50s
they couldn't really horrify you
because they were limited what they
could share they had to pull their
punches i mean i feel like it was really
right probably like the 70s before the
door before the doors got blown off with
[ __ ] like texas chainsaw massacre and
last house on the left you could see it
where even in the show yeah yeah yeah
psycho was what 61 62 1960 1960 all
right psycho and they psycho was the
beginning of [ __ ] that was a slasher
didn't show the slashing but they made
you think you saw that slashing but it
was all plausible [ __ ] was crazy
living in a damn hotel thought he was
his mom
he had gained they knew about ed gaines
that freaked him out yeah and and but
the thing is is that to do that in in
the crown strains of the 50s or the 6th
or the very early 60s you had to be a
genius at writing
yeah there weren't very many geniuses of
writing interested in doing horror
albert hitchcock was a quote was the
only thing they had he was badass though
he was good he was really good yeah
because most of the horror was just like
low budget kind of stuff just like
sci-fi they didn't it wasn't taken
seriously it was a genre like i said
probably until the 70s yeah but from
hitchcock came out and when when people
saw psycho they were like oh okay yeah
yeah
you know horror is a real genre if you
do it right
it's scary you know so
you can you can give it a hit you can
hand it to hitchcock all right although
let's be honest
hitchcock was watching movies from the
30s too
yeah so
he didn't pull it out of nowhere you
know that's the thing nothing ever comes
out of nowhere every every artist you
know
even though sometimes it seems like
they're completely doing their own thing
or they're on their own wavelength
everybody has their own uh influences
everybody has a set of influences yes me
the first real good horror movie from
the 30s and i was like yeah that's a
badass flick
boris karloff bella lugosi the black cat
a satanic millionaire military dude
[ __ ] sacrifices his unit out in the
[ __ ] what was it the austro-hungarian
war oscar pr prussian war over which war
it was
he sacrificed his own unit to consecrate
a ground to build an evil castle
and he's [ __ ]
weird incest stuff and necrophilia and
yeah like i said they did weirder [ __ ]
because you had like stuff you had stuff
like in the 40s like cat people which
was kind of like hey if she gets
sexually aroused she turns into like a
werecat yeah so there was that like they
didn't show it show it but they totally
like implied that that's what i've never
seen the original dr fu manchu they say
it's good too boris karloff but it's
kind of like
it's like people say well it's good but
you know he's dressed up as a chinese
guy that's not man it was the 30s
you know what i mean and and that's just
kind of what that boris karloff dressed
up boris karloff had the role of like
many different races of people you know
[ __ ] white guys like in ancient
egyptians chinese guys because a lot of
people realized that
karloff was indian he was half indian
so you know he kind of had an ethnic
flare to him but he could be any
ethnicity he wanted that's what that was
the beauty of of cinema and and theater
you could be anything as long as you
could pull it off and he could he could
be anything and i want to see a doctor
food man chew the original though yeah
it's real good
but yeah scenes and [ __ ] yeah that's but
so yeah like like you said in the 50s
they were kind of like having to toe the
line
so yeah but within those constraints i
feel like william castle did a good job
of like just basically giving the kids
what they wanted like i said it was just
like going to a carnival and riding like
a scary fun house ride where it's just
like fun you know what i mean that's
what they could do that's what i mean
and so i think that he was like the
really the best purveyor of doing that
like i said later on uh after horror got
taken more seriously you know then it
was a whole different ball game yeah
which was sci-fi had alien had an
element of horror in it yeah it scared
the [ __ ] of me when that bum got that
blob on his hand was it was eating him
up and it just ate up his whole body
that was horrible especially for the for
that era that's yeah that's pretty
[ __ ] up even for now
it was very early 60s i think wasn't it
the blob was 62
61 62 maybe it might i thought it was
earlier than that but i could be like i
thought it was 58 maybe 58 okay i could
be remembering that was about as hard as
you were gonna get back in those days
because of those codes that they had
there wasn't it wasn't no real rating
system it just had to be general
audience everything had to be general
audience
and uh but that came real close
and they still kind of had to make light
of it with silly rock songs and [ __ ]
jokes towards the end but yeah it's like
it's not real
[Laughter]
but um
it seemed like in this era sci-fi tended
to effectively do horror better than
horror did
and like you said that's probably
because they had plausibility and
other things you know you believed it
because it was an alien
yeah like an alien could be an alien
might be able to do that sure right so
yeah so don't go into like if you
haven't seen house on haunted hill don't
go into it like thinking it's gonna be
scary or anything like that but it's
just like a fun like i said it just
reminds me of like halloween you know
what i mean it's kind of just one of
those fun halloween you just kind of
have it on the background and the
halloween party and there's kind of like
scary [ __ ] going on like fake skeletons
and stuff and it's just fun it's just
like a fun sort of ride now they remade
this in 1999.
um
several people they had started this
company called dark castle and they
started it with the express purpose of
remaking like making their own
low-budget horror films too but mostly
like remaking
kind of like 50s horror movies like for
modern audiences right so i mean they
called it dark castle because of william
castle and so they ended up um doing
this movie they did house of wax which
wasn't a william castle movie but
whatever it was from the same era uh
they did 13 ghosts they did all that
kind of stuff now interestingly the 1999
house on haunted hill it kind of has the
same
setup it's not
great but it's not terrible i actually
didn't hate it the cgi uh sucks ass but
like by today's standards um but it was
actually still pretty fun
interestingly though uh the 1999 one
goes a lot more into
the history of the house actually it's
not even a house it was like a
was a asylum
and
the remake also makes it much clearer
that the house absolutely is haunted
um even though it still has kind of the
noir subplot
but uh the guy that owns the house in or
the guy that rents the house in the
movie is like an amusement park tycoon
type of guy
so that's how he pulls off like all
these tricks and everything but it is
actually haunted and they almost went
this is really weird but they almost
went like in a cosmic horror direction
they went in a thing where
all of the people that have died in this
house
kind of like all came together into this
one sort of shape-shifting entity which
is just called the darkness
so i thought that was an interesting
angle it goes like way far afield from
the original source material which like
i said just left it ambiguous as to
whether the house was haunted or not but
so i thought that was kind of i don't
know if i loved that but at least they
did something different as i said the
cgi in that movie is god awful
but it's pretty fun it's like has some
gory [ __ ] in it you know it was a good
time it's not a great movie but you know
they and they remade 13 ghosts too which
was almost exactly the same story but
they had like all these kind of big
stars and it was kind of fun
but you know so uh do you have anything
else you would like to add okay so house
on haunted hill as i said it's in public
public domain uh always a good time
watching vincent price uh my favorite
part watching him [ __ ] bicker with
that with that wife of his and that
whole like convoluted plot and
everything but yeah it's just like a fun
like i said just like a fun little
haunted house ride
fun thing to put on at halloween your
kids can watch it and it's not too scary
remake is decent i didn't love it but i
didn't hate it uh it's worth watching
though but it's a lot different than the
original so let us know what you think
about it in the comments and that will
do it for this movie retrospective we
will see you guys on the next one bye
you